مشاهدينا الكرام نحن نتحدث عن هذه المنطقه
في البلقان صربيا وكوسوفو والمشتعله منذ
عشرات السنين هذه الازمه رغم انها خفتت في
السنوات القليله الماضيه ولكن هذه الازمه
تبقى احدى اكهم الازمات التي اشتعلت في
منطقه البلقان كما نشاهد على الشاشه صربيا
وكوسوفو وهذا المحيط
تركيا اليونان بلغاري رومانيا واوكرانيا
النقطه البالغه الاهميه التي تشهد حربا
منذ اكثر من عام اذا ما انتقلنا مباشره
الى خريطه صربيا وكوسوفو نحن نتحدث عن هذه
المساحه وهذه الحدود
المشتعله ان صح التعبير بين الدولتين ولكن
هذه الحدود
تشتعل نتيجه صراع يبدو او كما يقال بانه
صراع
صراع على الهويه ان صح التعبير نتحدث عن
صربيا التي فيها حوالي سبعه مليون ساكن
ونتحدث عن كوسوفو التي يسكنها ملي
من بين اثنين مليون في كوسوفيا في كوسوفو
هناك 120 الف صربي من العرقيه الصربيه
يحملون الهويه الكسوفيه ولكنهم ينتمون الى
العرقيه الصربيه وموجودين بشكل اساسي في
المنطقه الشماليه من كوسوفو هذه المناطق
التي شهدت التوتر خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه وكانت ايضا خلال شهور قليله ماضيه
ايضا شهدت نفس التوتر لانه هناك اتهامات
متبادله بين الطرفين بان
الكوسوفو تقول بان الصرب يتحرض هؤلاء من
اجل اشعال هذه المنطقه
وكوسوفو تقول ان هؤلاء يحركون المنطقه من
اجل التدخلات العسكريه التدخلات العسكريه
كان وزير الدفاع
الصربي قد امر بدفع قواته نحو الحدود وهذا
الامر الذي انعكس توترا في العلاقه بين
الطرفين كم صوره اقرب الى هذه المنطقه فن
نتحدث عن هذه المناطق الاساسيه في المنطقه
الشماليه من كوسوفو وتحديدا هذه
الاقاليمبودوك ولبوسوفيتش هذه المناطق
الثلاث التي تشهد الان هذا التوتر هذه
مناطق حدوديه تشهد هذا التوتر مع تقدم
القوات الصربيه نحو الحدود بحسب قرار وزير
الدفاع الصربي وهذا الامر الذي يشعل هذه
الازمه من جديد ونحن نتحدث عن حوالي 120
الف صربي يحملون الجنسيه الكسوفيه موجودين
الان يشكرون حوالي 4% من تعداد سكان
الكوسوفو لتكون هذه المرحله في هذه
المنطقه تحديدا قد تنتقل الى مواجهه مسلحه
لان هناك مطالبات في هذه المنطقه بفرض
حاله
حاله يعني استقلال او ما يشبه بالاستقلال
او حكم ذاتي في هذه المنطقه لصالح صربيا
لتكون هذه المنطقه احدى ابرز المناطق
المشتعله الان مع التحالفات الدوليه صربيا
تتجه روسيا وكوسوفو تتجه نحو